brendan is with us in Knoxville
hey Brandon welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show Uncle Dave how about those
basketballs baby man are they killing it
or what they're doing it they're doing
it
hey Dave I may get a little emotional
but hang with me if you came in there my
wife and I are both teachers and 2015 we
had a daughter she had some learning
disabilities and she wasn't walking so
fast forward to 2017 I started grad
school or had some characters pushing me
to move forward in these things so I
thought you know the wife and I talked
we talked about cash flowing it we're
gonna do that so in 2017 the bottom
falls out intentionally the car into
grad school making good grades and
making progress and they they told us
that I've added an Alexander disease
which is a terrible diseases we mention
we take their life before she's a
teenager we were looking at thirty eight
thousand dollars worth of said we this
two calls and of course when the when
the news came I freaked out a little bit
and so we started saving so now we have
student loans to go with that so I was
just going to ask your opinion do we
stop and do we just save real hard and
there's a little curvy over there this
we have some great friends and they
started raising minute for us because
we're going to problems of Philadelphia
and such system specialists and things
so we have an account with about 3/4 of
my wife's
incomes of her salary just kind of
sitting there for us to travel and do
what needs all this has so I was just
going to ask you okay I'm sorry
thank you the the math part of the
equation is the medical needs and the
travel needs that your daughter has
are they going to be covered by this
account from the fundraising that that
was a goal and is there nothing is there
enough there to do it for the traveling
and medical right now yes we just don't
know how much is how much is anus
account much is in that account okay and
how much are you spending on travel and
medical on your daughter right now when
we head up to Philadelphia each time and
it's fitting that I can stay close to
the hotel and she's got six trips saved
yes and how many trips how many trips do
you in just making a year your phone
broke up one per year one per year right
now based on her aggressive this is more
if we need extra help right so you've
got six years worth or five five years
worth I'm sorry six six years six years
at five thousand each thirty thousand
right okay yeah that's out there are
pretty good ways that we pretty much can
say with comfort we got that part
covered thank you for the friends right
in the middle of everything else aren't
good and then you've saved up how much
in your own emergency fund when I got a
little nervous we had a thousand if you
take out okay that doesn't work if you
went seventeen into debt but you were
cash flowing it why wouldn't you have
seventeen in your savings well we
started a cash flow and then it was oh
none of us and we started to throw me
into that so if I wasn't as well oh that
makes sense
yeah all right so you're making sure the
daughter is taken care of that's what it
should be because she's a priority one
your school completion is not nearly the
priority of that and cleaning up debt
okay and so I would suggest you get
to the baby steps you've got a $30,000
fund over here for the crisis that
you're facing that's mathematically the
crisis is behind you for a while mm-hmm
and so I would just go back to your
normal baby steps and let's get down to
$1,000 and let's start cash flow in
school again because you shouldn't have
a big drain on your budget for your
daughter's need you've got the 30,000
over to the side so you should be able
to cash flow school going forward right
I'm looking to be an administrator next
year yeah let's just work through that
snowball here take $4,000 and throw it
at your smallest debt and let's just get
out of debt you know you got you got
knocked off the wagon you didn't fall
off the wagon yeah but now we're gonna
crawl back on yeah because there's no
that the point is is that nothing we're
doing there is causing your daughter to
be in jeopardy otherwise we would change
the program right yeah you can run
simultaneously run track you're doing
good I'm sorry you guys are facing this
that's it's tough news man and tough
thing to fight through it takes your
breath away but it sounds like you're
doing the right thing sound like you got
good people in your corner and you
finished up your income is going to go
up now and your career is continuing so
those parts are all good news to go
there there's always a bucket coming out
of the well and always one going in and
there don't every one of us have
something that we need to do something
going on we wish wasn't and something
going on we're really celebrating at all
times this is the Dave Ramsey show